[MUSIC PLAYING]
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
There is my son.
He will be 11 tomorrow.
I promised him I would
tell everyone that.
Because normally,
I just say he's 10.
He will be 11 tomorrow.
And I started out as a parent
going, what is this operation,
parenthood?
What is expected of me?
What do I want for my child
in 20 or 30 years' time--
happiness, success, fulfillment?
Right now what makes him
happy is programming something
in Python and then
playing on the trampoline
when it doesn't work.
I don't know what's
going to make
him happy in 30 years' time,
and nor can I give it to him.
So at this point, I want to
ask who here is a parent,
a mum, a dad, a
concerned citizen
about the future, a
caregiver, an aunt, and uncle?
Let's see.
All right.
OK.
So I guess we're all
in the right place.
So welcome, everybody.
Thank you so much
for having me here.
I do want to thank a colleague
of yours, Linda Scotti, who
isn't here today.
And she read "Raising Thinkers"
before it was published.
And she suggested
that I definitely
have to come and
share it with you,
and to Caroline for being
such a gracious host
and for making it all happen.
So operation parenthood,
where do we begin?
Now when I started
looking at this,
I thought, well, perhaps--
hello, Anthony.
He knows exactly where to
begin on operation parenthood.
He's got his own ideas.
I thought-- well, I
realized that I was not
sending my son into a
fixed point in the future.
I was actually sending
him on a journey.
And how he behaved within
that journey and the decisions
that he made on that
journey would actually
create that future.
So could I not
try and understand
the forces that would be
shaping that future, what
skills he would need
along the way to bring him
happiness, success, fulfillment?
If I could equip him with good
decision making and good ways
of thinking about
information, then he
could sort out happiness,
fulfillment for himself.
And that was the plan.
So I started talking
to and listening
to the people and
the companies who
are actually shaping the
future, companies like Google.
And I was asking them
about employment practices,
what they're hiring for in
the leaders of tomorrow.
I scoured job boards.
I attended conferences and
talked groups, and over
18 months.
I also spoke to
people who are running
apprenticeships programs,
which by the way,
are very much back in fashion.
Because they're
filling gaps left
by schools and universities.
And along this journey, I came
up with several conclusions.
But mostly, I got
good news, bad news,
and I learned that I was wrong,
very wrong in how I approached
this first part of the journey.
So can we just start with the
good news, get it out the way,
and then the bad news.
So the good news
is that by 2020, it
is estimated by
McKinsey that there
will be 85 million job
vacancies for medium
and highly-skilled employees.
That's fantastic.
By the time my
children grow up, there
will be jobs if they
choose to take jobs.
The bad news is that it is
estimated by McKinsey that
by 2020, there will
be 85 million--
or employers will face 85
million job vacancies that they
cannot fill.
How is this possible when
university enrollment
rates for the current generation
are higher than for any others?
This was curious.
And this is when I
learned that I was wrong.
Because I truly believed that
the future belonged to STEM
graduates-- science, technology,
engineering, and maths.
And I will show you a snapshot
of the kind of information
that I was receiving from
companies and from my research.
So what it turns out is that
it isn't a lack of skills,
but there is a
mismatch between what
employers-- or what universities
and schools are producing
and what employers
are looking for.
And this is very much at the top
of the agendas of governments.
But you see, with
STEM graduates,
schools are in a
very good position
to teach STEM
subjects, because it
follows the traditional
teaching methods--
teach, test, repeat,
correct, repeat--
whereas the skills that are most
sought after today for tomorrow
are slightly harder to
teach, but not impossible.
So I was invited to a conference
at Microsoft headquarters
in the Thames
Valley near Oxford.
And it was a small
affair, just attended
by the heads of the tech
companies based there.
And they were talking
about the future of tech.
And the entire morning
was spent talking
about this lack of skills,
this skills gap, this skills
mismatch.
And the first question
of the morning
was, well, what skills are
missing from job applicants?
And I wasn't entirely surprised.
This is just a screenshot
of the screen that I took.
I was expecting slightly
more hard skills.
But we've got critical thinking,
creativity, collaboration,
communication.
And I don't know about you,
but none of those soft skills
yet feature on my son's
report, on his grade card.
He doesn't get a grade for
communication, collaboration,
cooperation, critical
thinking, problem solving.
And the UNESCO report
summed it up really well
when they said that technical
skills were the bedrock
of an industrialized nation.
But when a country moves up
into a fully fledged service
economy, high level thinking
and behavioral skills
are what continue to
drive economic growth.
Now this got me very excited.
Because I had spent the
last 12 years in Asia,
in Singapore and Hong Kong,
teaching critical thinking
and decision making.
I knew what behavioral
skills were.
I was working with
the government,
with the private
sector, and on an MBA
and an undergrad program.
But I was teaching
it to the adults
in two of the top three
school systems in the world
because they had not learned
these skills at school.
And being very
forward-thinking governments,
they knew they had
to bring these skills
in if they wanted to continue
to move their economies forward.
So I knew what high-level
thinking and behavioral skills
were.
But I'm interested to know what
you guys think that they are.
And I have a very good idea that
you know exactly what they are.
So let's hear.
What do you think
constitutes high level
thinking and behavioral skills?
It's not as fluffy
as it sounds--
promise.
Some ideas, let's hear.
Who has some ideas?
Caroline, kick us off.
CAROLINE: High
level thinking and--
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
And behavioral skills.
CAROLINE: Decision making
or cognitive skills
or how to approach a decision.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Absolutely,
making decisions-- yes,
having a system for
making decisions.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Leadership.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Leadership,
absolutely-- common sense
is less common than you think.
Absolutely.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Thinking
two steps ahead.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
Thinking two steps ahead,
so having a way to think about
whatever you're working on.
Right.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Understanding
communication styles.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
Communication styles,
yes-- knowing what's
going on when people
are using different styles.
Yes.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Emotional
intelligence.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Absolutely.
Thank you very much--
emotional intelligence.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Intercultural skills.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
Intercultural skills.
Thank you.
What else?
We could go on and on.
How many of these skills
are on your child's report
card, if they're there yet?
I know most of you
have young children.
But even in four or
five years' time,
they will not appear on
your child's report card.
Because they're not
being taught them yet.
So the skills we
were looking for
are critical thinking,
innovation and problem solving,
emotional and social
intelligence, systems thinking,
adaptability, risk taking and
resilience, and above all,
this idea of raw intelligence.
Now there are two ways
of looking at thinking.
There's thinking about stuff.
And that's what we
learn at school.
We learn what's called
crystalline intelligence--
facts and information.
Then there's thinking
about your thinking--
how to think.
This is fluid intelligence,
or raw intelligence.
And the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation,
realizing how important this
fluid or raw intelligence is,
not just for the future,
but for right now,
they commissioned a
study, a really big
and well-credentialed study, to
try and understand if schools
that were able to improve grades
on crystalline intelligence--
so the stuff we
learn at school--
if schools who were able to
improve that could also improve
tests on fluid intelligence
without any extra intervention.
And what do you
think they found?
Were children able to improve
fluid intelligence just by
doing better at school,
all these things
we've spoken about?
No.
I see lots of head shaking.
No-- unequivocally
no, they were not.
So doing really well
at school does not
produce an increase
in fluid intelligence.
Now this left me in a very
uncomfortable position
as a parent.
Because I knew what
these skills were.
I knew how to teach them.
But I was absolutely not going
to spend the few precious hours
that I had with my son every
day teaching him stuff.
I wanted to be a cool
parent, after all.
That's a very rare thing, right?
So I wasn't going to do this.
But the more I dug and
the more I researched,
the more I spoke to
people and schools--
I interviewed 22 schools--
the more I realized that no
one else was going to do this.
And that's where the book
was born, where I realized
there was a message here.
And we needed to tell it.
Problem was, I didn't
know how to do it.
I didn't know how to do it
in a way that was interesting
and wouldn't take up our time.
My son has enough lessons,
kind of extra everything
classes on top of schoolwork.
So I got stuck.
And I started writing up all
the information that I had
and looking at and
thinking about it
and thinking about how
I worked with adults.
I trained them, I coached
them, and I consulted.
And out of all
those three things,
the most effective
way of getting
them to change behaviors,
to learn new things,
to get rid of behaviors
that weren't particularly
good for decision
making and thinking,
was through coaching--
not particularly
technical coaching,
really simple but
powerful conversations.
And that's when I tried
coaching with my son.
I took a situation
when he was eight.
And I thought, all right,
I can listen to him
and hear what he thinks and
then tell him what I think
and what I think he should do.
Or I can turn it around
and try and have a coaching
conversation with him.
So instead of telling you
what a coaching conversation
with a child looks like,
I'll play you one so
you can hear it.
And I want you to
think how this is
different to the
typical conversations
you have with your children,
or if your children are still
not quite having conversations,
the kinds of conversations
that your parents had with
you when you were faced
with a difficult decision.
And the setup up to this
particular conversation
was that my son is a
small boy for his age.
And he was being verbally
bullied at school.
And one day on the bus,
he was just sitting,
minding his own
business-- so he tells me.
And these bigger boys were
overpowering him with words,
but quietly so that the
teacher couldn't hear them.
He got so frustrated
and so angry
that he swore at
them very loudly.
And the teacher heard him.
So he got into trouble.
So when the dust settled,
we had this conversation.
It was our very first
coaching conversation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Honey, how did you feel about
what the boy said to you today
on the bus?
- I felt angry, really angry.
- So he called your baby.
Is it true?
Are you a baby?
- No, I'm not a baby.
- So why did it
make you angry then,
if you know it's not true?
- Well, because
he said it aloud.
And everybody on
the bus heard it.
And I felt really embarrassed.
- Ah, could you have stopped
him then from saying it?
- No, not really.
- So do you think you
reacted in the right way?
- No, I don't think I did.
But I mean, I was so
angry, it just came out.
- OK.
So what would you have liked
to do differently then?
- I would have liked to
said something cool that
doesn't get me in trouble but
gets him to stop annoying me.
- Ah, OK.
So you want a line
that you can say
when you get angry
that sounds cool
but doesn't get
you into trouble?
- Yes.
- OK.
- But what?
- Well, you tell me.
What can you say every
time someone calls you
a name, something
that you won't forget
and that you can use in
different situations?
- I could tell them
to stop annoying me.
I could tell them
that I'll tell them
that I'll tell on them if
they keep on annoying me.
- Hm.
I'm not sure.
Does that sound cool?
- No.
- So tell you what-- how about
you think of two or three lines
that are short and easy to
remember and then we chat about
them tomorrow after school and
see which one will work best.
- OK.
- OK, cool.
[END PLAYBACK]
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: And we did
chat about it the next day.
And I still didn't think
they were cool enough.
Of course as mummy, as a
writer, I had so many lines
that he could use.
I knew exactly
what he should say.
But I bit my tongue.
And I played it cool.
And I waited.
The following day, he
came up with this line.
And I was so incredibly
proud of him.
He said, Mummy, I'm
going to say this.
When somebody calls me a baby
or a nerd, I'm going to say,
you may think that
I'm a baby or a nerd
but that doesn't make it true.
I thought, wow,
for an 8-year-old
to come up with that, to
say, I respect the fact
that you have an opinion.
But I don't have to believe it.
And he did that by
himself at eight.
He still uses it today.
It's given him a tremendous
amount of confidence
to stand up for
himself in a way that
doesn't get him into trouble.
Because the teachers go, well,
you know, it's OK what he said.
You know, he respects
that you have an opinion.
But he doesn't believe you,
which he's entitled to do.
So how is that
conversation different
to the typical conversations
we have with our children?
Let's hear it from you.
What's the one big difference
that you heard there?
AUDIENCE: You let them
think for themselves.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Absolutely.
I guided him with my knowledge,
with my experience as an adult.
All I did was guide him and
let him think for himself.
And this then
became, I tried this.
And I continue to use these
coaching conversations.
Other parents started to use
these coaching conversations
to start delivering all
these skills, this huge menu
of skills that our children
aren't getting anywhere else.
And the results have
been astounding.
So it became the vehicle then
to really impart the knowledge
that I knew my son would need.
So there we go.
So of course, "Raising Thinkers"
was a four-year journey for me.
And today, I'm leaving
out almost everything,
because I only have half
an hour to talk to you.
And I know most of you
have young children.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to leave you with just
a couple of really concrete tips
that you can start using with
your children
immediately-- well,
from about the age
of four to five--
that will really
make a difference
in how they think
about themselves,
other people, and information.
So the first one is,
of course, as parents,
we make better decisions
than our children.
Because we've made more.
We have more experience.
We understand risk.
And we have this enormous
internal database
of decision outcomes, what's
worked what hasn't worked.
So we tend to make
decisions for them.
And something that I've found
in working with graduates
and undergraduates and
then coming to the UK
and working with
young entrepreneurs
is that they really, really
battled to make a decision.
They actually battled
to have a structure
to think about their options
and then to pull the trigger
and make that decision.
And then you start to
realize, in talking to parents
and reflecting on
your own experiences,
that that's because
most of their childhood,
we've made the
decisions for them.
And they've only started to
get this enormous database
of decision outcomes
from early adulthood.
So what if, as parents, we
start from about four or five,
allowing our children
to make decisions,
controlled decisions?
So we become
decision architects,
where we can ask quite simply
for a four-year-old, peas
or beans for dinner?
Very simple-- those
are the two choices.
But you can pick
them, and I will
prepare whatever you choose.
And as they get
older, the decisions
can become more
complicated, more complex.
But you still design
their choices.
So they start to understand
that there are consequences.
And they have to accept them.
This is enormous for a young
child, especially one that
is used to having parents
make their decisions for them.
As you saw in the conversation
I had with my son,
he got to choose what
he wanted to say.
But I really helped and
guided him get there,
using my knowledge
and my skills.
You know, your children
will have so many teachers
in their lives.
They will have a
couple of mentors.
And if they choose you,
that's great, as a mentor.
But they will have
very few true coaches.
So designing these
decision outcomes for them
becomes part of that role,
when it's appropriate.
The next one is in
understanding risk.
Because again, we're much
better at understanding risk.
Our children have no
experience of what's
out there, all the nasties
that can really happen to them.
Yeah, it's true.
But they have something
that most of us--
certainly what I
see in my work--
that we have lost along the way.
And that is an
incredible imagination.
And if you look at the
financial crises that
have happened over
the last two decades,
pretty much all
of them have been
billed as black
swan events, things
that we couldn't
have seen coming.
But some commentators who
thought a little bit deeper
about these events have
actually seen that they
were a crisis of imagination.
We didn't see them
coming, because we
do our projections
and our risk analysis
based on the past, the
present, and the numbers.
And a lot of what I'm doing
in working with adults
in the boardroom
is reintroducing
this idea of telling
narratives to understand risk.
So when your teenage daughter
comes to you and says,
I want to date this guy
who's really, really cute
but has a bit of a bad
reputation-- she might not
actually tell you that.
You might hear that
from the friends.
How about you ask her
to sit down without you
and think about the absolute
best that can happen out
of this relationship
and the absolute worst
and how that will affect
her social standing,
her personal perception, her
Facebook profile, her Facebook
feed.
What could possibly go wrong?
And when she's had a
chance to think about this,
you then sit with her and
discuss these options.
How much of this risk
is she prepared to take?
Help her come to a conclusion.
And seven times out of 10--
I won't say 10 times out of 10--
seven times out of 10, if
you help your child actually
reach their own conclusions,
they will stick to them.
And that's
particularly important
when you're not around
in the teenage years.
Now "Raising Thinkers" goes
through a lot of this parent
as coach and all these
skills, but it also
looks at how the brain
develops from before birth
all the way through to the
teenage years and the role
that we as parents play
in that brain development.
That blew me away,
because it was not
something I knew I had
any particular role in.
But we do.
And especially in
the teenage years,
it looks at how
they perceive risk
and why the initiatives
that schools and governments
have been introducing to try
and reduce teenage risk taking,
why they're not working.
Because they're actually
focusing on the incorrect.
They're focusing on controlling
risk, not getting teenagers
to understand risk.
And it's got to do
with how the brains are
growing in that particular
point in their lives.
And the last thing I
want to leave you with
is to suggest that you take
your children to the movies.
Don't just take them and
leave them there, but actually
take them to the movies,
watch something with them.
It must have
interesting characters
and dialogue, real dialogue.
So that might exclude some
of the superhero movies
on at the moment.
But there are other
movies available.
And when you're
done, when you're
driving home, having
pizza with your kids,
chat to them about
the characters,
what one knew that another
one didn't know, why there was
conflict, how they resolved it.
And how would your
child have resolved it
if he was a superhero
without superpowers?
What would he have
done in that situation?
And what you're doing here
is developing theory of mind.
Now as you can already
imagine, theory of mind
is the foundation of social
and emotional intelligence.
And it is incredibly important
as they grow up, start working
with other people and teams.
And believe it or not, it is one
of the most important aspects
of good decision making,
emotional intelligence.
So there's a tip.
And ultimately,
what we're trying
to do through all these
ideas is to develop skills
that artificial intelligence
will find hardest to fulfill.
Yeah?
I'm not going to say
won't fulfill or give you
a particular time line,
because who knows,
but that we'll find
hardest to fulfill--
the human element.
So just to be clear--
I left out-- theory
of mind is the ability
to create a map of what somebody
else intends, is thinking.
And that thinking
and those intentions
are different from your own.
So if you say to a
small child, Daddy
thinks that the
Earth is flat, they
will generally believe then
that the Earth is flat.
But there is a
difference between Daddy
thinks that the Earth is
flat and the earth is flat.
The earth may be round
or wobbly or bumpy,
but to make the difference
between what Daddy thinks
and what reality is.
And when it comes to fake data,
fake news, alternative facts,
this is becoming really,
really important.
When I started writing
"Raising Thinkers,"
that wasn't even a word.
But it's a thing now.
In 1917, Einstein had a problem.
He discovered that his brand
new theory of relativity
was giving him
dodgy information.
It was saying that the
universe wasn't stable.
It was either expanding
or contracting,
which of course, was rubbish.
Because it looks pretty stable.
So he developed what he called
the cosmological constant.
And he popped it
into his formula.
And it controlled for
the effects of gravity.
It held everything
together, according
to his belief of the world.
A Belgian astronomer--
well, a Belgian priest
an amateur astronomer,
George Lemaitre,
he came to him 10 years later.
And he said, you know what?
I don't think you need
your cosmological constant.
I think the universe
is expanding.
Of course, he is
a complete madman.
I mean, what's this guy talking
about, expanding universes?
60 years later, that
became the foundation
of how we understand
the universe today--
the Big Bang Theory.
Now I don't know what I don't
know, like Einstein didn't know
or what he didn't know.
And we don't know where
we're sending our children.
But if we can give
them a system to think
about this new information
that will be coming their way,
then that would be
incredibly helpful.
So what you will also
find in "Raising Thinkers"
is that I've taken all the
work that I do with adults,
and I've really squeezed it
down to its very essence.
And I've come up with the seven
habits of good decision makers,
like brushing your
teeth twice a day.
So this is information
that does we go through
in the book in
detail, again in fun
and interesting ways to
do with your children
as they grow to help them think
about this spread of fake news
and fake data and
the information
that they are working with.
My corporate mission
has always been
to change the world
one thought at a time.
Because if people can
make better decisions
and think more soundly about
themselves, about other people,
about information, then they
will make better decisions.
And that will affect their
family, their communities,
their businesses.
But when I became
a parent, I did not
realize the enormous
responsibility
and the enormous
power that I had
to shape somebody's mind, their
thoughts, and their outcome.
And I now know if my son
can make better decisions
and think more soundly about
himself, about information,
about other people, not only
will I be changing his outcome,
but I may just change his
community, his company--
if he chooses to
work for a company
or becomes an entrepreneur,
whatever it is he
chooses to do.
And if enough people do this, we
can actually change the world.
And I think that is very
necessary right now.
So I invite all of you, whether
you have children or thinking
of having children or have
cousins and nieces and nephews,
to join me in continuing to
raise your children as thinkers
and hopefully change the world.
Thank you very much.
Let's have some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
So thank you very much.
I'm going to jump straight in.
And the first question
I'd like to ask
is, what behaviors are not
good for decision making?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: I
think what is not good
for decision making
is an inability
to question information, an
inability to question sources,
and certainly an
inability to question
your own understanding.
So we talk quite a bit--
I mean, I'm a
behavioral economist.
So the work I do is in
understanding mental biases,
how we process
information, how who we are
affects how we see the world
and the decisions that we make.
And probably the most
limiting in terms
of making good decisions is
falling into our own biases
and not understanding
how we frame information.
Because how information
is presented
is more powerful than the
information itself, so good
question.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
So you mentioned
at the very beginning
that to question where
you get your information
from, or maybe
in that case, your parents
and the information
that they give you or the
advise that they give you.
And that's, I
guess, something we
have to encourage
our children to do,
to not just blindly listen to--
or accept everything that's
said to them or even for
also our peers and the people
that we work with or report to.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
When I was growing up,
my parents would say
to me-- because I would
say why a lot, annoyingly.
And they would say to me,
just because I said so.
Yeah?
A couple of you are laughing.
Because yes, as parents, we
get to the point where we say,
just because I said so.
Because I know better.
And I make better
decisions, so just take it.
And sometimes we don't have
time to do the coaching
and to sit down and
explain everything.
But at some point, we have to
be able to say to our children
that it is OK to ask us why.
My son is allowed to--
lots of times, being a boy,
a preteen, lots of times
he makes decisions on the fly.
And we have to say to him
afterwards, that was wrong
and explain to him why.
And if he still
doesn't understand,
he'll come to-- he's
allowed to come to us
and say, I need more
information, Mum.
I want to know why you
say, no, I can't do that.
And we've promised him.
And it's a contract between
my husband and myself
that we will take the
time to explain to him.
And as soon as he
understands our thinking,
that there is actually
something behind it--
because sometimes kids think
that you just say no because,
right?
The minute he understands that
there is thinking behind it--
he's 10.
He's old enough to
reason, absolutely.
He gets it.
And he may not be happy with it.
But he works with it.
So we have this rule that
we are not allowed to say,
because I said so.
And it's tough as hell.
Because sometimes you
just want to say that.
But you know?
It's making all the difference.
And he's at a school
where-- he was in a school
previously where
he would do that.
And he was actually told
to be quiet a few times.
He was being
disruptive in class.
We took him out of that school.
It took me two years
to find a new school.
But we found him a new school.
And that was the
deal with the school,
that if he asks respectfully, if
he can ask why the teacher says
that, they must be comfortable
that they will give him
an answer.
And it may not be in front
of the class, but afterwards.
And the school was
delighted to do this.
Because it was so
refreshing that here
was a pupil who could
do this respectfully
and out of curiosity, which
was quite different and making
waves a bit in the school.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
I imagine it was tough for
a few teachers at first.
That's great.
Can I ask, what
advice would you give
to parents or aunts or uncles
on encouraging an anxious child
or teen to start
making some decisions?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: OK,
so anxiety in a child
usually comes from
inexperience, from-- especially
for a child who
likes to be organized
and needs to know one thing
follows another thing.
Anxiety normally
starts in a child
when memory starts to develop.
Because suddenly, you're
faced with a stranger
that you don't have information
in the memory bank about.
Or going to a new school--
there's a lot of
anxiety around that,
because you don't
have any information.
There's nothing in your
memory about that school.
So if a child is
particularly anxious
and they need to
make decisions, it's
about priming them
as much as possible.
I found having worked
in Asia for a long time
in Asian cultures, standing
up, making decisions on the fly
is quite a difficult
thing to do.
Because it's not
part of the culture,
certainly not part of
Confucian cultures.
So giving a child space
and time, prepping them,
exposing them to information--
not making the decision
for them, but encouraging
them to maybe read up or speak
to people, getting them
comfortable with ideas
and concepts.
Again, all of this takes longer.
But this is the difference
between take-out parenting
and actually a
good, wholesome meal
that is going to nourish
the body and the mind.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Thanks.
That's great.
Thanks.
Fantastic.
Are there any live
questions in the audience?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Is it on?
Yeah.
My question is how to deal with
a child or a teenager which
is irrational or
dishonest about the facts?
So in the example you gave about
a young female teenager that
wants to go out with
the hot guy at school,
and she might sit down,
as you recommend, to think
about the consequences.
But she skews the
reality and decides,
well, it's going to be really
nice to start going out
with him.
And she doesn't see any bad
consequences on the horizon.
How do you balance making
them make their own mistakes
and protecting them?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Of
course, because life
gets kind of serious at
round about that age, right?
And again, giving frames
and how we view information,
they will frame that information
for their own outcome.
But there's a reason
they want that outcome.
And you as a parent, if
you understand the coaching
conversation, which the
book is quite clear--
and it's not a difficult thing,
by the way, these coaching
conversations.
But at that point, for you as
a parent to try and understand
why they so desperately want
to go out with this kid,
what is the reason behind it?
So put all that risk assessments
and everything aside and sit
down with them or get
a friend, somebody they
trust, somebody they speak to,
to actually sit down with them
and say, all right,
so what's behind this?
Why this guy and nobody else?
And you will get some
interesting information
as to why they choose
that particular boy.
And that is something that
you will then work with first,
before you even get
to the risk thing.
Does that actually
answer your question?
But the thing is, you're
missing information from that.
If she is continuously skewing
the discussion towards I
will do this because-- so she's
only looking at the positive--
you need to understand
why it is that she's
insisting on pursuing this.
Because you would have
helped her by then
to actually look at
all the negatives.
And she is quite happy
to brush those aside.
So there is-- and it's
usually a social game.
So there is some kind of social
game that she gets out of it.
You go back then to this, well,
I'm going to be really cool.
And it's going to light
up my Facebook feed.
And it's going to be
brilliant for me socially.
Then we start
talking about, well,
the necessity of
this social need
and the long-term
consequences of that.
It's a process.
Yeah, there's no there's
no quick fix to it.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's great.
Thank you.
It's over here.
AUDIENCE: I have a question,
maybe a slightly different view
on raising critical thinkers
in [INAUDIBLE] countries,
where you don't have freedom of
expression, freedom in speech.
And I'll explain why.
I grew up in Soviet Union.
But when I was 10, the
Perestroika started.
It wasn't that time.
But I do remember my
mother telling me, at home,
you can say what you want.
At school, you can say only
what you've been told on TV.
So I was--
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Wow, that
is a difficult question.
AUDIENCE: --you can't-- there
are different consequences
for saying things
you might believe in.
So how you do explain to,
like, 10, 12-year-old children?
What would be your advice?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Wow.
OK.
That is a tough one.
For me as a parent,
your first port of call
is to protect your child, right?
So up until, I would
say the teenage years--
and again, I have absolutely
no experience with this,
so don't quote me--
but up until that
point, your primary goal
is to protect them.
So they need to understand the
framework, as you explained,
within which you're working.
The danger is they
get into a situation
where their true beliefs
come out in public.
And that is dangerous.
So it also depends,
I guess, if you're
able to leave the country,
where this becomes valuable,
or if this is not a
skill that will ever
benefit them in any
which way, will only
get them into trouble.
So as a parent, you do
your own risk assessment.
Because the consequences
are not standing up
against a teacher who might tell
you to shut up and sit down.
It's very different.
So if they're capable of
understanding that duality,
then to have that
critical assessment,
perhaps keeping it to things
within their own life,
their immediate world, and
teaching them within that.
But again, how do you
teach a child to criticize
their brother or
to think critically
about what their brother
says, but not what
the government says?
So to be honest, I do
not have an answer.
I think that is an incredibly
interesting question.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah,
that's a great question.
It's very hard [INAUDIBLE].
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: It's
something to think about.
Yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: How to
advise your child for that one.
We have some questions
at the back of the room.
Thanks, John.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that this book,
it's kind of useful from
five onwards, right?
But I have a two-year-old.
So my question is,
is there something
that I can do so that I don't
prep him in the wrong way
so that when we
reach five, I can
coach him to be
better [INAUDIBLE],,
coaching him [INAUDIBLE].
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Oh, dear.
There are no wrongs when
it comes to parenting.
No, the book is not
only useful from five--
the coaching conversations
are only useful from five,
because at that point,
they're able-- they
have a greater theory of mind.
They're able to understand
consequences and have
enough vocabulary
for conversations.
But in fact, what
the book does is
it looks at how the
brain develops right
from the beginning.
And it looks at the foundations
of fluid intelligence, which
is memory capacity and
processing speed in the brain.
It also looks at how a baby's
brain develops in response
to its environment, which
to me was incredible,
that if you take a child-- which
has happened in many conflict
countries-- and put
them in an orphanage
where they do nothing but
sit in a cot all day, devoid
of love and contact and
music, and their brains
are actually smaller than
other children's brains.
Because they haven't had an
environmental stimulation.
And the connections in our
brain grow from stimulation.
So actually, we go right
from the very beginning,
from before your baby can talk.
And we look at ways
to actually stimulate
processing speed and
memory capacity, games
that you can play.
It's all games.
We look at things like
when my son was young,
we lived in Singapore.
And there are the parking lots.
There'd be 5,000 parking
bays in a parking lot.
And it would be over 17 floors.
And you forget where
you parked your car.
So I would always just
put it on my phone
so that I knew when I came
out, which floor I was on,
which parking bay, which color.
It was kind of a whole list
of things we had to know.
But eventually, we
played this little game
where we put the phones away.
And we said, OK, let's remember
where we parked the car.
And we would look at the colors.
So we would go, it was number
17 B on the seventh floor.
And we'd come up with rhymes--
so 17 baboons in the whatever
it was.
And these are fun things
that are absolutely
developing that
brain capacity that
will be so important later
for all these other things
that your child needs.
So if you're loving your
child, talking to your child,
and actually spending
time with them
away from devices and phones
and that sort of thing--
because a baby can--
a young child can only
see about 30 centimeters
in front of them.
And that is so that
they can focus,
so that they're actually
not distracted at all.
And if you can have that quality
face-to-face time talking,
using words as big as you want.
And let them hear it.
They don't get that from a TV
show, because-- from cartoons--
because the facial
expressions and the words
are not congruent, or
necessarily congruent.
So it's very important
that they hear us.
So keep going-- very important
from the very beginning.
It's actually a pivotal age,
that sort of under three.
In fact, all the critical brain
mass that a child will have
is fully developed
by three and a half.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
I'm you sure
you're probably
doing a great job.
Don't be too hard on yourself.
Do we have another question
at the back there, John?
Then we've got a few
at the front as well.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you spent
some time coaching young
adults, graduate students,
et cetera, about these skills.
And how does that differ,
in your experience,
from coaching a young child,
like your son or someone
else, some other minor?
And again, how
might that coaching
differ from self-teaching
these skills,
so how might these
different modalities
to acquire these skills differ?
And what does that tell us?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: OK,
so the big difference
between working with
young adults and children
is self-confidence
and self-belief.
I find that young children
are still very much looking
to you for the answers,
whereas young adults feel
they have the answers.
They just want you to
check on their thinking.
And that's just two different
modalities, two different ways
of working with them.
So with young children, you have
to be their choice architect,
give them the guidance.
Because they don't know, right?
They know what they've
experienced from friends and TV
and superheroes and stuff.
So there's a lot more in
terms of intervention.
There's a lot more of
yourself that you put into it.
Working with young
adults, it's a lot more
checking what they're thinking
and definitely not telling them
what you think, unless
they ask, but helping them
discover for themselves, so
very much like the conversation
that you heard but actually
asking those questions,
just probing, probing,
asking, asking,
letting them go off and
discover, come back, check,
and work with it.
And when it comes to
working with yourself,
it's quite difficult. It's the
most difficult of all of them.
Because you are asking
questions about your thinking
with the thinking that is
producing the thinking.
So this is
particularly difficult.
This is why having
a sounding board--
not necessarily a coach,
but just somebody to say,
hey, this is what I'm thinking.
What do you think?
How would you find
fault with me?
So again, it's something--
and I'm doing a PhD now
in this critical thinking
decision science.
And what I'm finding,
the foundation of it
is the ability to be
reflective, to actually say,
these are my frames.
This is where I'm coming from.
But that's what I think.
Hang on.
Is that really true?
Are these actually my
frames, and going back,
speaking to other people,
checking yourself.
I have this
particular background.
This is who I am.
How does it affect my thinking?
Because that affects
your decision making.
Because that affects how
you process information.
So the big difference
in working with yourself
is brutal honesty.
And that, my friend, is the
hardest thing in the world.
But it's doable.
Yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's great,
so questioning your biases,
your frame of reference,
maybe even arguing
against yourself?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
Absolutely, yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Or the other person
would say, their point
of view might be.
Won't We have a question
up at the top of the room.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
A couple here.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
[INAUDIBLE] our last one there.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is related
to the one about raising a
child in a totalitarian system.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
Oh, the hard one.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So what does the child's safety.
The other part is that it's not
even a totalitarian society,
but I think any society.
We have a lot of things that
are enforced by societies
say that are counter--
essentially not logical.
And if you raise your child
to be a critical thinker--
I'm trying to be
critical thinker.
And I get a lot of
frustration out of that.
Because for example,
I have to operate
in environments
which are extremely
illogical and frustration.
And it doesn't bring me
happiness in some way.
You know, there is a component
of unhappiness because you--
for example, if people around
you force you to obey something
that doesn't make sense.
So if we are talking about
raising a happy person,
how do you raise a person
who is a critical thinker
and is not getting happy because
of the state of the world?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: That
is a brilliant question.
And my son has already
hit up against this.
Brexit-- he is so
unhappy about Brexit.
And he can't understand Brexit.
And he's in an
international school.
He grew up in Asia.
He loves England.
And then Brexit happens.
And he's trying
to understand it.
Now, this is theory of mind.
This is the ability
to say that I
have a certain way of thinking.
And for me, that is
logical and correct.
And there's a big question
about what is logical
and what is rationality.
But I have to respect
that other people have
a different way of
thinking because
of their different
frames and filters
and where they were raised
and how they were brought up.
So part of that maturity
and that ability
to be happy with my life
is to know that this
is my decision making.
And these are the boundaries
within which I work.
I cannot affect everybody
else's thinking.
So you know--
AUDIENCE: But they
can affect yours.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: That's the
problem I'm talking about.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Yeah, Yes.
But if you know that you're
making the right decisions--
you see--
and this is the coach in me--
nobody can make you unhappy.
You choose to be unhappy.
And it's easy for me to
say that, sitting up there.
I know that.
But again, it is that choice.
And the minute somebody
else makes you unhappy,
it's a powerlessness
that you're accepting.
So again, that critical thinker
in you-- because emotions
are about 60% of our
thinking, of our decisions.
And that emotional
content that is coming in
is not making you happy.
And you're giving power to it.
So the idea is to
understand, well,
what power do I have
over other people,
and then being able
to step away and say,
this is my decision making.
And it's good.
You cannot change other
people's thinking,
as much as we cannot
change Brexit.
But it's what we do with that.
I got so unhappy with
Singapore and Hong
Kong having the top two
education systems in the world
that I wrote a book.
And I feel better about it.
Because I'm doing
something about it.
Because it used to
drive me insane that--
I went looking.
Because schools keep saying
they teach critical thinking.
I was going, really?
Let me see what
they're teaching.
And it turns out that
what schools are teaching
is a critical application
or a real world application
of mathematical concepts.
Fantastic.
Kids need that.
We all need that.
That's not critical thinking.
Critical thinking is
thinking about your thinking.
So there is no quick
answer or quick solution.
But again, it's
that having power
over other people's decision
making, where the limits are
and how much you're
prepared to accept.
And that is not even a
critical thinking issue.
That is more an emotional issue.
It doesn't help, but
does it make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it does.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
OK, fantastic.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Thank you.
So we're just out of time.
So as we close, what's one
thing we can all do today
to improve our decision making?
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
Question ourselves
before we question the facts.
Question how we're looking
at the information,
question our frames.
That's one thing.
That's a couple of things.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
No, that's great.
The more the merrier.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ: Yeah.
I was sitting with
a coach last night.
And she was showing
me this new system
and profiling tool
that she's looking at.
She was so excited about it.
And it had positive
and negative.
And I kept thinking, well,
who decided that those
were positive traits?
And who decided that those
were negative traits?
Because in Asia, a lot of
what we as Western people
think are negative
are super positive.
And my immediate reaction to
any new piece of information
is to say, oh, hang on.
Where does this come from?
Who decided it was like this?
And does it work for me?
And do I accept it?
So not to say there's
anything wrong with what
she presented, but for me,
it's important to question it.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's great.
Thank you so much.
And thank you for coming
[INAUDIBLE] today.
TREMAINE DU PREEZ:
It's a pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]